this is the kind of question where I'm
going to take advantage of what we
looked at in terms of uber general turn
earlier on this morning so that you can
see how I don't have to write out all
the terms and that will come so before I
get to the general term I'm gonna take
this and what I'm looking for is in the
expansion of this thing which by the way
has how many terms think about with me
just look at the right here party on one
plus X to the power of 11 how many terms
without habit if I expand just that
there'll be twelve terms right you start
from zero you go all the way to 11 and
there's the top terms now I expanded
that thing I would have twelve terms but
then I multiply it by this which has
three terms right so therefore there
will be these twelve then another 12
minutes now that well there'll be 36
terms and I assume there will be a lot
of items in there right so some of them
are going to collect together but it's
gonna be a bit of a mess so here's what
I'm going to do I'm actually gonna do a
partial expansion of this so that you
can see what is going on and how I'm
gonna use the general term to help me so
he's my commercial expansion maybe want
to follow along with me if I just expand
out the left hand pair of brackets right
what this means is to lots of this minus
5x lots of this plus x squared
lots of it do you agree that's I told it
means okay so this one is this my
business buy this
that's fine okay now you can see that
out of each of these rows there will be
exactly one term that contributes to the
X to the 9 in the final line do you see
that follow with me right have a look at
his first line for instance if you get
forget about the 2 for a minute in here
there will be exactly one term which has
an X to the 9 in do you agree yeah that
term gets multiplied by 2 and eventually
it mixes together with these other guys
and that'll be part of the expediter
have a look at this line here okay again
the 1 plus X 3 11 it'll give you an X to
the 9 term but I don't want that term do
I actually don't want it why not
okay I want a different power match the
reason why it's not X to the power of 9
is because it gets multiplied by X when
I expand on my brackets out so will
actually become an X to the 10 therefore
the time I really want easy here is the
X to the 8 to do agree because once I
get an X the eighth term out of here
it'll get expanded with this and it will
become part of the X to the 9 are you
fooling with me now one last time in
here which of the terms do I want that
will contribute to the other night
eventually it'll be the X to the seven
because it gets multiplied with this
awkward okay so here's now what I'm
going to do I'm going to know that I can
work out what each of these are because
each one of these is going to look
exactly the same right all the twelve
terms would be identical okay
which means all 36 will be just
different values of like powers and NCI
notation
okay so let's write down together what
will be the general term of this
expansion three pieces what's the first
one I'm looking for the general term
right it's gonna be 11 see ah
right it's the general term so it could
be any term at the moment yeah so
there's that binomial bit then is going
to be some of these how many roommates
this general term
that many and then there'll be some of
these namely this many sorry elect
myself I always do that
you okay with that now let me just point
out remember I said to you we've written
it with the one person the XO second but
it's exactly the same if I turn it
around yeah
in this case I actually am gonna turn
around I wonder if you can see why if I
write like this instead one can you see
why this just had a tiny edge this will
still give you the right answer but this
is just a teeny little bit easier to
work with can anyone see what
yeah almost other way around 1 ^
anything even something messy and weird
it's always going to give you one right
so if you've got a messy power and
you've got ones which by the way happens
on what you might as well attach the
messy-looking power to the one then you
can just not worry about depends that
make sense okay so in this bracket I
want the X to the 11th turn Knights
right power yeah in this bracket I want
the X to the eighth term and in this
bracket I want the X to the seventh
so that will pull the fall out right now
watch I'm going to stop writing equals
because the thing I'm gonna write next
is not all the terms it's not the whole
expansion it's just the ones that I want
okay so I'm gonna write the X to the
ninth term equals okay one step in time
firstly up here it will be 2 times okay
have a look what value of r it's an easy
one
will give me an X to the ninth
our equals nothing right do you see by
the way had I chosen this version still
click on earth but the alguna benign the
our would be too because that'd be 11-2
me gb9 still works it's just you've got
to do subtraction in your head and if we
can avoid that why not so here we go
here's the bit inside eleven say nine
I'm here on time X to the 9 1 squared
you Caroline that's the particular term
in here that's useful to me and I eat
and all the rest and I move to the next
part
it's a minus 6x minus 5x here and now I
pull out the X to the 8th Oh which I'm
actually very good at work me out now
it's just 11 see 8 X to the 8th one cute
baby see the the whole point of using
the general term is the details all the
leg McCoys and then you just put numbers
iam and that's that's the easy two last
one plus x squared okay can you tell me
what's right now 11 safe 7 X to the 7 1
to the 4 okay now clearly I mean we
compete we peak this so we didn't have
to worry about the ones I've I would
encourage you like I've said it maybe 20
times in the last five days okay that if
by the new expansion every term has one
two three pieces and even though ones do
happen a lot so they're nice and simple
they don't always happen so you want to
get in the rhythm of this piece this
piece this piece and then you can expand
can we just quickly work out the answer
well okay so you if you've already
evaluated everything else can I actually
get can I get some numbers so 11 c9 was
that gonna be 110 thank you and there's
an X to the 9
oh that's you boy double this is 55 bit
is that right yeah I wasn't clear what I
was like that in here I'm gonna get
minus eight four five times 265 165 and
again there's X to the ninth you can see
that right and then last one plus 11 c7
thank you okay and then I would write
the final line and the reason why is
because this line is important this like
matters to me it shows me you can
understand what's going on not just
football so now you can tell me answer
which is
that's the exponential okay so that was
still a lot of legwork like we have to
think really hard to do it but clearly
it's superior to writing out all 36
terms and then identifying which ones of
their mother once we'd collect them and
go from there okay so this is how the
general term is useful to us right it's
not just kind of curious but it's a real
tool that's quite handy